look the one of the largest facts in the
government is alcohol to back on
firearms that's true
they support murder and alcoholism
and rampant death through alcohol why
wouldn't they support porn it's like the
third largest industry in the world
makes sense well we'll be right back
with our sponsor which is pornhub
it was such a serious talk about but i
really do believe it i'm learning more
and more about what i think gets
subsidized by the government
creepy [ __ ] like i think they fund a lot
with this jeffrey epstein stuff i'm
i believe that the government can have
fun i think the government is chill with
so much shady [ __ ]
think about how much they hear you on
your phone think about how much they log
what we're doing and saying on your
phone and i know people like they're not
listening to you that's so dumb
and they would go why would we waste
time listening to
every person's phone call it's like
because you have the ability to do so
if you can why wouldn't you you would
i could imagine someone in a room they
pay a guy that looks just like george
to sit in a room probably seriously yeah
and to just random phone calls all day
get clicked in and he sits there
he's got his little tiny little earbuds
and he's
licking the air you know he's like he's
like i'm just eve teasing yeah
he's eating he's teasing i just eat a
phone call
and he logs in whatever sets him off
he sends it into the government and they
compile these lists and so they're
trying to organize and understand
society
you know if someone were to surveil you
and say look through a glass window say
for instance yeah would they find your
life
to be interesting on a date today me
yeah like what are your
nope do you pick your nose a lot nope
nope the only thing that i'd be
embarrassed about getting out like the
one thing i probably wouldn't want
people to know is like um
i should make my ring sometimes after i
work out uh
the smell of my booty on my shorts
but how could we i couldn't see that
through a glass window
do you smell it do you sniff it
sometimes i smell it okay that's but you
know what that's a
that's a smart thing to do to that's
what your nose is for to assess the
damage yeah i want to see how stinky
this
the butt sweat is and it's so intriguing
that scent man when it
hits you right now it's real it's rea
yeah it's in your lymph nodes are you
the guy that also smells your
like clipped toenails i do i smell my
floss yep
i do floss yeah yeah you have to it's
human nature
there i saw there was a video on twitter
that was it was inaccurate but i wish it
was real of kanye west eating
um earwax did anybody see that you know
i used to eat ear wax when i was a baby
so when i saw him i was like yeah no big
deal oh it's so crazy you know it's
you know it it's it they're like little
bitters they're like little
little bitter eaters like you know
bitters that you add to your drink
oh jesus like for an old [ __ ] cocktail
mixology
what is what what's the other one called
capers they're like little caterpillars
like little ear capers when i saw kanye
do that i was like whoa
somebody tweeted this is your king i
thought that was so smart i was like
that's very funny
but but truth be told i see so many
people pick their nose and eat it now
i'm not even surprised
anymore i see it all the time bobby eats
his boogers nah
i mean there wouldn't if you